I was so nervous when I started dating this guy that I like
we've been dating now for over a year
I was so nervous when I started dating him because he had four kids
like he was fine with it
but then I was like
oh my god
what about when he still tells his family
what if they're like
oh my god
you're crazy like
what are you doing
blah blah blah
like some of the shit you do hear people say about single moms
um
his mom just sent my kids
each one of my children
all four of them
a little Easter card with $10 inside for all of them
so needless to say
it is not the end of the world to leave your marriage and start over
because there are lots of beautiful people in this world that
you know
see you for more than a single mom and see your children as more than a burden
and they're willing to welcome you and love you
and that's way better than being in a toxic marriage